so if you ever feel like you're addicted
to your phone you're addicted to social
media this is the hack that takes two
seconds that saved me so much time I
actually turned my screen into black and
white and so you can fix this in the
settings and what happens is all of a
sudden you stop reaching for your phone
as much because it becomes less
addicting and if you do it for 24 hours
I promise it's the craziest thing in the
world when you pull it back up again and
you actually turn color back on you'll
be like whoa and you'll realize why it's
so addicting to begin with and so if you
have those struggles at least like I did
it was one of the best and highest Roi
hacks that I had to make my phone less
addicting